I want to ask you about this honor and
what does it mean to you and what will
it mean when you step on that field to
sing the national anthem everything
every everything first the honor that
they would even think of me to do
something this important I'm serious
the fact that I'm at home mm-hmm Atlanta
Georgia is my home my background my my
family that lifted me up as well as the
group and Gladys Knight & the Pips and
and and showed us the way to keep
growing that kind of thing this city
it's amazing I don't I don't I don't
know if we get enough attention as far
as Atlanta is concerned you know because
well we went through a lot you know and
we came and we came out and made it
positive and the way maybe you know the
way we came together and and and
compromise and did all of those things
to help Atlanta become that the Atlanta
that it is now when it was announced the
people tried to get after you and you
clap back on you had to tell them no
stop you said I'm not I'm not playing
with you stop but it was the thing you
said that it was important as he said
I've earned the right to be out there
well well in a way you know I I think
about it because I grew up with it
mm-hmm you know this is this is my
country this is my state my city that
kind of thing and I love my country it's
really simple as that you know and I
choose all my songs you know by what
they say of what they would make me
first and then everybody else feel you
know and I don't know I think about the
people that fought and and marched and
died and did all of those things for our
country and
proud to just honor them by singing that
anthem you know they did a lot you know
yes they did they did so much so here's
to you guys
mmm the star-spangled banner is not an
easy song to sing but you get though you
do you put your own twist on it or do
you just go with the original note
original was alright yeah I mean it was
alright
you know I have emotions when I when I
sing it mm-hmm
and yeah it's it's been quite something
it's not melodically that hard to sing
you know mm-hmm
but I always choose my songs by its
lyrical content you know and sometimes
you can get into being fresh with a love
song mm-hmm
well you can get into something you know
eltz that that's making a statement and
it may not be all the time perfectly
right you know but the fact that I love
this country and that's really what it's
about
want me to there is a you know one of
the big bets in Las Vegas is the
over-under the time of the you know
about that don't know you know right
okay you know how'd you how are you
dealing with that people been calling
you say can you just let me know will
you be under two minutes my sister she
called an ass see steel sea steel plates
no look she was like I need to know
[Music]
you